[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette édition spéciale où
nous allons revenir sur l'aiguille des
meutres qui se sont produites dans
beaucoup de villes des Yvelines nuit des
meute et de violences qui font suite
vous le savez à la mort du jeune Naël à
Nanterre tu es mardi lors d'un contrôle
policier odeur de voiture qui brûle
bruit d'explosion tire de mortier contre
les policiers et les commissariats cris
de colère des assaillants contre les
policiers ou cris de joie lorsque les
policiers reculent intervention
compliquée et incessante des pompiers et
une tension dont rien indique qu'elle
puisse retomber dans les heures ou dans
les jours qui viennent alors dans cette
édition spéciale nous allons revenir sur
ces événements avec nos avis de Béatrice
pion bonjour bonjour vous êtes débuté
redescence de la deuxième
circonscription troisième
circonscription des Yvelines Noureddine
Noureddine bonjour vous êtes journaliste
à marmite FM et puis vous connaissez
mieux que personne la vie des quartiers
que vous suivez depuis des années tant
mieux que personne je retire cette
sur des événements qui ressemblent à
ceux qui se passe produit aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui s'était passé en 2005
exactement avec on a plongé dans les
archives de TV 78 et voir comment on
peut trouver des similitudes peut-être
avec les événements de 2005 c'est vrai
que c'est une cote minute qui explose de
temps à autre et puis Nicolas Maville
bonjour vous êtes proche vous êtes le
maire de La Verrière alors je crois que
là vous revenez sur les lieux où ils
sont passés des événements pendant les
deux nuits qui qui viennent de se
dérouler
justement qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à La
Verrière qu'est-ce que vous déplorez et
comment peut-être vous expliquer ce qui
s'est passé
oui désolé je suis en voiture là
justement pour me rendre au bois de
l'étang écoutez des émeutes toute la
nuit dernière qui ressemblait à à des
scènes des scènes de guerre dans des ne
quittez pas
des scènes quasiment paramilitaires avec
des jeunes en cagoulé avec des
jerricanes d'essence qui était
incontrôlables qui ont semé la terreur
la panique dans le quartier qui ont
parfois fait du porte-à-porte dans une
tour pour dire qu'ils allaient enflammé
l'ensemble du bâtiment qui s'en sont
pris à deux de nos écoles deux écoles
sur trois de la ville qui sont
intégralement incendiés
j'étais ce matin donc pour pour voir les
familles c'est des enfants en pleurs qui
me demandaient s'ils allaient pouvoir
récupérer leur leur père de lunettes
leurs vêtements leurs petits cahiers où
il y a tout leur souvenir de l'année
c'est des enseignants sous le choc c'est
du personnel dégoûté c'est des familles
sidérées on est dans un état de
désolation assez assez terrible de s'en
prendre à des écoles c'est c'est honteux
à votre avis c'est une des manifestaires
des émeutes des plus violentes que vous
ayez connu
moi je pense qu'on peut difficilement
faire pire que que de s'en prendre aux
écoles la maison de quartier a aussi
étant partie incendiée il y a un
habitant qui s'est engouffré dans la
dans la maison de quartier pour enlever
le cocktail Molotov qui est d'ailleurs
en urgence à trappe et je le tiens le
saluer il y a une autre gardien qui est
totalement
épuisé de la nuit qui a essayé de faire
son possible pour protéger l'école dont
il avait la responsabilité on a un
habitant qui a réussi à à préserver
notre crèche qui a aussi été menacée on
a notre mairie qui devait aussi être
incendié et heureusement un habitant
réussi je dirais à raisonner les
quelques jeunes qui voulaient s'en
prendre à notre bâtiment municipal donc
on est dans dans je dirais c'est un SOS
que je lance c'est vraiment un cri du
cœur et des nous parce que là on sent
que tout le monde est dépassé les forces
de l'ordre étaient dépassées les
pompiers étaient dépassés ils ont eu je
crois 160 interventions
instantanément donc ils ont été pris de
cours ils n'ont pas pu intervenir à
temps dans nos écoles puisqu'ils ont
fait preuve de de d'entraves ils ont
fait l'objet d'entrave avec des
guet-apens des tirs de mortiers qui s'en
sont pris au véhicule de pompiers donc
je vous dis des scènes de guerre du
décolle qui est totalement ravagé qui
fument encore non c'est l'horreur
absolue et quand vous dites aidez-nous
c'est vous appelez qui à l'aide
bah tous ceux qui voudront nous tendent
la main
on a je vous dis nous c'est plusieurs
millions d'euros de dégâts on a
des enfants à accueillir dans la semaine
qui viennent donc on va avec les
services de la Ville
faire au mieux on a après une sorte
voilà 150 enfants à accueillir donc on
va trouver des solutions
dans d'autres structures dans dans
d'autres écoles de la ville mais on est
on est dans un état de détresse donc je
tire la semaine d'alarme et j'appelle à
l'aide tout ceux qui voudront nous aider
pour financer la nouvelle la nouvelle
école pour assurer des navettes entre le
quartier et la future école provisoire
je salue le préfet le préfet Courtade
qui est venu immédiatement la délégué du
préfet je salue la
[Applaudissements]
les gens ont vraiment locaux qui
viennent d'ailleurs mais quelle est leur
objectif je ne comprends pas
au secours quoi
comment je sais pas les députés le
peuvent venir en aide justement au maire
qui sont dans le désarroi quoi
visiblement oui bah je pense que vous
avez dû échanger avec la rectrice c'est
peut-être même je pense que j'ai changé
avec le cabinet du ministre cet
après-midi j'étais au ministère je pense
qu'ils prévoit de passer vous voir je
pense que que les écoles des alentours
de de la communauté d'agglomération vont
sûrement proposer de prendre quelques
enfants moins pour la rentrée parce que
c'est évident que deux mois seront pas
suffisants pour reconstruire une école
donc je pense qu'il va falloir trouver
des écoles avec un petit peu de place et
organiser des transports d'élèves pour
les amener donc sur des écoles
existantes pour le moment après le
financement je pense qu'il va falloir se
mettre tous autour de la table donc
c'est sûr je peux comprendre que la
commune n'est pas de quoi avancer
l'argent pour une reconstruction totale
bon il y aura sûrement des assurances
aussi je ne sais pas il y a une question
qui revient dès que le David on aura
tout à l'heure une interview d'Ali
rabais le maire de Trappes c'est
l'absence au fond de force policière
est-ce que vous regrettez vous aussi de
pas avoir assez de force de police dans
ce genre d'événement
bien évidemment bien évidemment je pense
que on veut toujours plus de moyens plus
de moyens policiers j'espère que le
commissariat d'agglomération d'Élancourt
dont le projet
avance pour le moderniser sera efficace
mais visiblement on a eu affaire à des
attaques des attaques
orchestrées organisé qui ont déstabilisé
bien évidemment nos forces de l'ordre
mais que je salue en fait tout ce
qu'elle pouvait les pompiers ont aussi
fait tout ce qu'il pouvait encore une
fois je salue le préfet et tous nos
partenaires et qui ont répondu présent
immédiatement qui sont venus sur le
terrain qui sont prêts à nous aider
financièrement aussi pour investir
notamment pour des nouvelles tables des
nouvelles chaises dans le le lieu
provisoire qu'on mettra à disposition
donc c'est un appel à l'aide mais qui
est d'ores et déjà entendu par par les
partenaires que je tiens à saluer une
nouvelle fois
je tiens saluer les familles je tiens à
l'huile personne de l'éducation
nationale qui a fait preuve d'un
professionnel extraordinaire c'est des
écoles
qui sont avec qui on est enfin avec
lesquels on travaille depuis très
longtemps on a un partenaire avec le
Centre de Musique Baroque de Versailles
on a investi dans le numérique avec les
petits robots pour la programmation
informatique c'est des écoles
magnifiques qui suscitait beaucoup
d'admiration et et et d'inflexion et
donc de voir l'état de désolation
les ruines de cette école c'est d'autant
plus douloureux pour pour nous pour le
personnel mais on va se relever c'est
aussi ça la force je dirais d'un groupe
c'est de faire face aux épreuves et donc
on va on va se relever tous ensemble et
et j'ai bien conscience madame la député
l'a dit que l'ensemble des partenaires
seront rendez-vous et je les en remercie
d'avance
bonsoir Monsieur le Maire un mot déjà
sur cette nuit là qui qui arrive est-ce
que vous la redoutez et savoir quel va
être votre programme quels vont être les
premiers travaux là dans les dans les
jours qui suivent
alors est-ce que je redoute la nuit la
réponse est oui on a beaucoup
d'inquiétudes on sollicite le préfet
bien évidemment le commissaire pour une
vigilance extrêmement accrue on a
sollicité l'agglomération aussi pour
remettre les éclairages puisqu'ils avec
la sobriété énergétique l'éclairage
était éteint la nuit ce qui suscite
quand même beaucoup de de crainte dans
ce type de contexte donc on a demandé à
l'Agglo de remettre l'éclairage qui sont
en train de faire j'espère que ça
pourrait être fait dès ce soir il y a
des complexités techniques on a mobilisé
une cellule de crise
on a déjà accueilli dû accueillir les
enfants avec nos structures avec nos
animateurs on a dû faire face pour ne
pas traumatiser les petits bouts de chou
et puis cette semaine s'organise dans
des structures municipales qui sont
mises à disposition donc des des
enseignants pour accueillir nos élèves
et puis on va devoir vider l'école on va
devoir récupérer le matériel que l'on
peut reprendre et à la rentrée
vraisemblablement accueillir nos enfants
dans l'école régionale de premier degré
le RPD qui est sur la verrière et qui a
quelques espaces disponibles pour
accueillir nos enseignants nos enfants
et puis on essaie de travailler là sur
une offre de de navette pour pouvoir
acheminer autant que faire ce peu nos
familles dans cette école provisoire qui
vraisemblablement accura les enfants de
l'école du bois de l'Etang l'année
prochaine une question
vous libère Nicolas
rapidement je sais pas si ça m'a échappé
peut-être est-ce qu'il y a un dispositif
spécifique qui va être mis en place un
dispositif policier vous avez rencontré
le préfet dans la dans la journée vous
avez certainement des contacts également
avec les services du ministère de
l'Intérieur est-ce qu'il y a un
dispositif spécifique qui va se mettre
en place à la verrière ou sur toute
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
écoutez ce que je vais dire et peut-être
peu rassurant mais mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est quand même le
flou
le préfet bien évidemment
à répondu à la positive positivement en
disant que des forces de l'ordre se
rémobiliser il y avait un escadron de
gendarmerie mobile qui est déjà en fait
mobilisé hier donc j'ose espérer que
l'État sera au rendez-vous je n'en doute
pas
mais j'ai l'impression quand même qu'on
fait face à des événements inédits qui
surprennent par leur ampleur et qui
malgré toutes les forces de l'ordre du
monde sont compliquées à à faire face
mais mais le préfet était positif le
commissaire aussi et les services de la
ville sont en alerte j'ai eu les
renseignements territoriaux aussi très
souvent au téléphone donc bien
évidemment que tout le monde est sur le
qui-vive mais on invite au calme on
invite à la responsabilité des parents
ne laissez pas sortir vos enfants
vraiment s'il y a un soir ou faut pas
les laisser sortir c'est ce soir là et
puis on est nous aussi avec nos services
de médiation sur le qui-vive pour
appeler au calme au calme et à la
vigilance la plus totale
merci beaucoup Nicolas David on vous
laisse vous rendre dans ce quartier du
Bois de l'étang je crois c'est ça
merci merci et merci de ce témoignage on
va reparler avec vous Béatrice Piron
avec nouredina aussi de ce qui s'est
passé au cours des deux nuits
précédentes on va peut-être d'abord
faire un état des lieux qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé comment cette nuit on
regarde un sujet de Régine ralech
des rues ravagées des voitures calcinées
dans le département des Yvelines des
violences sont éclatés toute la nuit du
28 au 29 juin à Poissy des feux
d'artifice et des émeutes ont éclaté
dans le quartier de la Coudraie la ville
de trappes à quant à elle était prise
pour cible le Supermarché Carrefour des
Merisiers a été pillé le centre culturel
de la Merise a été vandalisée le
Commissariat a été pris d'assaut par des
tirs de mortiers lancés par des jeunes
cagoulés
quelques kilomètres plus loin des
établissements scolaires ont également
été pris pour cible à La Verrière deux
écoles ont été incendies l'école des Noé
et du bois de l'étang et à Guyancourt
les bâtiments d'Alembert et Vauban de
l'université Versailles Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines ont été endommagées des scènes
de chaos ont été recensés dans d'autres
communes des Yvelines à Villepreux
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles Les Mureaux
et l'encours ou encore
Chanteloup-les-Vignes au total la nuit
dernière les pompiers des Yvelines ont
dénombré pas moins de 1200 appels 45
interpellations et trois blessés légers
du côté des policiers
Nicolas Davy Béatrice Piron
on a l'impression quand même que cette
cocotte-minute qui explose comme ça ça
vient de situations un peu lointaines
souvent
je pense que personne n'aurait été
capable de la semaine dernière de
imaginer ou d'anticiper ce qui s'est
passé cette semaine ça a été vraiment
très subi
je n'ai pas d'explication donc on voit
le reportage on a des villes un petit
peu
partout dans les Yvelines qui ont été
touchés
pour l'instant je crois qu'il faut
analyser il faut se donner le temps de
l'analyse de l'enquête pour l'instant je
n'ai pas du tout de d'informations
complémentaires
on peut penser on en parlera tout à
l'heure sur ce qui avec Nouvelliste sur
ce qui se passe à Trappes notamment qui
a quand même des relations complexes
entre les policiers et des habitants de
quartier et que ça date pas d'hier ça
date pas même de la mort de Dael oui et
c'est un élément déclencheur évidemment
on sait que régulièrement certains
quartiers et même certains élus
politiques en veulent beaucoup à la
police mais
je pensais au départ que ça serait
beaucoup plus localisé sur Nanterre que
ça serait cet après-midi sur la marche
puisqu'on avait annoncé la marche de la
colère donc je pensais que ça serait
quand même localisé sur le 92 ou plus
proche de Paris mais visiblement ça
atteint toute la France
des grands métropoles
on va peut-être se pencher sur ce qui
s'est passé à Trappes là aussi il y a
une nuit extrêmement agitée et Michael
el Mido et Julien Leroy se sont rendus
sur place commerce vandalisé et voiture
détruite tout au long de la nuit du 28
au 29 juin des violences ont éclaté dans
la commune de Trappes ces émeutes font
suite à la mort du jeune Naël tué par un
policier lors d'un contrôle routier à
Nanterre le 27 juin victime de ce chaos
cette boutique de meubles installée
depuis 4 ans dans le quartier des
Merisiers a été en partie incendie avec
de l'essence le giron appelle les jeunes
à ne pas se faire justice eux-mêmes on a
été très choqué pourquoi parce que on
fait partie de Trappes on a ici on a
essayé de développer une activité ici
pour les gens de trappe pour eux pour
les familles et voilà d'avoir ça au
retour ça fait mal au cœur et j'ai envie
de leur dire que ça sert à rien de de
mettre le feu comme ça dans tout trap
essayer de calmer les choses une
centaine de mètres plus loin des
poubelles ont également été incendiées
devant l'hôpital privé de Trappes créant
de le jeudi dysfonctionnement en interne
s'attaquer au bien public non c'est pas
franchement
une bonne idée cette personne au final
et c'est je trouve ça dommage
aujourd'hui ces habitants espèrent un
retour rapide de la paix dans cette
commune de 34000 habitants laissez-nous
tranquille nous sommes dans une ville
populaire solidaire où il fait bon de
vivre à Trappes moi j'adore ma ville je
vis là par choix depuis 30 ans et j'ai
jamais vu ça et franchement j'appelle un
appel au calme là on voit du coup la
haine voilà ils ont la rage et je
comprends je compatis mais c'est pas
pour autant qu'on doit faire des choses
comme ça selon le maire alirabel et
dégâts sont estimés à plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros sur
l'ensemble de la commune pour la voirie
seulement
vivait à Trappes donc vous avez vu
vous vous avez une explication votre
montée soudaine comme ça de violence qui
va jusqu'à vandaliser un supermarché
évidemment il y a les violences contre
la police mais il y a d'autres actions
quoi madame la députée disait tout à
l'heure je ne comprends pas comment on
peut voilà brûler notamment une école
parlant du cas de la verrière et je
pense que c'est dans cette phrase que
tout ce que se trouve toute
l'explication et toutes peut-être la
ce que beaucoup n'arrivent pas à
comprendre un certain ministre avait dit
que comprendre ces excuser alors moi je
suis journaliste donc j'essaie quand
même de comprendre pourquoi pourquoi il
y a ces pourquoi il y a ces événements
il y a une
ça fait très longtemps que les relations
entre jeunes de quartiers notamment même
si le terme jeune bon il veut tout et
rien dire notamment les plus jeunes
populations de ces quartiers et la
police et très très tendu il y a des
épisodes qui n'ont pas été médiatisés
mais même récemment attrape par exemple
il y a une réunion entre les services de
la mairie le commissariat Trap est
certain jeunes qui ont bien voulu venir
rencontrer les forces de l'ordre pour
justement essayer de mettre tout à plat
par rapport à ce qu'ils jugent ces
jeunes être comme de l'humiliation
quotidienne par hasard moi j'ai discuté
avec des jeunes de Trappes c'est ça il y
a des contrôles incessants ils entendent
des rentes chez toi enfin
sans compter que maintenant s'ajoute à
cela voilà des
insultes racistes voilà que ces jeunes
prennent justement aux policiers
qu'est-ce qui va être le plus gênant
dans ces quartiers
la plupart des jeunes avec qui vous
allez changer ne sont pas contre le fait
que les policiers entrent dans le
quartier pour par exemple venir
contrôler une personne qui est
soupçonnée de trafic de drogue ou
d'autres choses encore plus peu plus
graves c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas le
point le point le plus important c'est
de sentir que un jeune de Bon Dieu est
considéré par la police comme un jeune
de Bon Dieu potentiellement délinquant
potentiellement vendeur de drogue
potentiellement porteur de tout ce que
peut véhiculer justement l'image de ce
jeune de banlieue et sur peut-être sans
jeunes de banlieue 1 2 3 qui vont poser
problème et bien les 97 autres sont
persuadés en tout cas par rapport aux
témoignages qu'on a et par rapport à ce
qui nous est rapporté que justement ils
sont stigmatisés humiliés et non
seulement eux ces jeunes mais maintenant
ce qu'on entendait pas avant également
les parents qui sont également cibles de
de parole déplacées de certains
policiers
et alors pour compléter vos propos nos
radine on retrouve le même phénomène de
l'autre côté en fait si une
incompréhension totale entre les jeunes
et les policiers parce que le phénomène
que vous décrivez et bien on le retrouve
de l'autre côté aussi les jeunes des qui
pour un policier et ben il considère que
le policier sera raciste viendra faire
des contrôles intempestifs non justifiés
et du coup il généralise et il se disent
ben 90% des policiers sont racistes
viennent faire des contrôles
intempestifs et du coup généralise aussi
donc finalement on a deux catégories
sociales si je puis dire
deux visions en fait qui s'opposent et
malheureusement qui semble aujourd'hui
en tout cas irréconciliables alors c'est
vrai il faut pas non plus faire
d'origine dans les violences aussi il y
a ceux qui veulent aussi prendre les
pouvoirs sur le quartier et sur les
quartiers ça existe aussi
c'est vrai que voilà il y a en effet des
torts des deux côtés mais il y a aussi
des temps que certains jeunes et des
difficultés avec la police mais ça
n'explique pas qui brûle une école ou
qui brûle un magasin de meubles ou la
voiture de leurs voisins qui qui vivent
avec eux dans le même quartier donc
le politique doit un moment se poser la
question de savoir qu'est-ce qui amène
des jeunes de 14 ans 15 ans
a brûler l'école
fréquenté par leur petit frère leur
petite sœur si il ne se pose pas cette
question si il n'arrive pas ou en tout
cas n'essaye pas d'apporter des
solutions concrètes
le problème ne sera jamais résolu si les
députés ne se posent pas cette question
d'essayer de comprendre au-delà des
dénonciations au-delà des condamnations
nécessaires il y a quand même quelque
chose
de 2005
que vous avez sur lequel vous avez
beaucoup travaillé d'ailleurs vous-même
et Nicolas nous en reparlera tout à
l'heure il y a il y a un changement qui
est important et qui
explique peut-être la flambée de cette
violence et le fait qu'elle se
transporte c'est les réseaux sociaux
ça joue un rôle essentiel vous ne pensez
pas justement à sur les réseaux sociaux
concernant la ville de Trappes il y a un
appel qui le matin je crois en tout cas
aux alentours de 11h midi qui a circulé
en donnant rendez-vous à des jeunes à
20h devant le commissariat de pour
venger de
venger la mort de Noël et il y a l'idée
dans des coudre aussi quoi voilà du coup
il y a une vraie gestion il y a une
vraie maîtrise de ces réseaux sociaux
parce que si vous voyez le message bah
il y a eu un espèce de flyer de qui a
été mise en place avec la photo du
commissariat avec le petit mot de
rendez-vous avec le slogan donc tout ça
effectivement est organisé est organisé
et préparé de là à dire est-ce que c'est
des plus grands est-ce que c'est d'où
cette personne de l'extérieur ça pour
l'instant
elle a pris ce qu'on parle de Trappes
j'ai eu tout à l'heure un entretien avec
avec le maire de trappes à l'irabet et
qui fait par au fond d'un certain
sentiment d'abandon
[Musique]
une situation chaotique qui a duré au
moins trois heures avec des poubelles
brûlées à travers la ville des
containers poubelles des abribus
détruits etc donc vraiment une situation
où on avait le sentiment quand même que
les les jeunes disposaient du terrain
qu'on avait quand même un sentiment
d'impunité pour les métiers qui à leur
église s'attaquer au commissariat de
police au Carrefour Market des Merisiers
qui a été littéralement dévalisé et
ainsi qu'à la poste on enceinte a été
fracturé et qui a également été en
partie dévalisé
[Musique]
des groupes de jeunes
quasiment tous les quartiers qui sont
relativement jeunes entre 15 et 20 ans
je dirais d'après ceux que j'ai pu voir
percevoir dans la nuit très déterminé en
découdre avec la volonté vraiment de
s'attaquer au commissariat de police
très mobile très regroupé également et
qui se sont donnés rendez-vous à minuit
pour un coup de feu d'artifice de
mortier d'artifice tenter de tirer les
impressionner les policiers qui étaient
installés au commissariat
[Musique]
des effectifs de police qui
manifestement étant insuffisant les
moyens il y a disposition du département
et du commissariat de d'Élancourt qui
chapote notamment les lignes de Trappes
n'étaient pas à la hauteur du nombre des
métiers donc cette diminution des moyens
cette éloignement du terrain aussi cette
distance qui se crée entre les policiers
et la population et en particulier avec
les jeunes des difficultés aussi liées à
des violences policières qui existent et
qui peuvent créer du ressentiment entre
la population et la police à tout cela
créer un cocktail explosif qui tous les
10 ans me donne lieu à des émeutes et à
chaque fois on fait mine d'être surpris
bien cette espèce d'ambiance où l'État
ne se préoccupe des quartiers expose et
bien ça vous dit à ce que les gens les
plus confiance en la République
[Musique]
quand on voit alors évidemment la
violence quand même de ce qui s'est
passé pour des deux dernières nuits et
notamment la dernière nuit en 2005 le
gouvernement avait décidé de d'établir
l'état d'urgence
là le gouvernement n'a pas décidé de le
faire jusqu'à présent est-ce que vous
pensez quand même que guérir une réponse
l'état d'urgence ça va pas être une
réponse d'urgence justement nécessaire
je crois qu'aujourd'hui l'objectif est
de calmer calmer calmer il est à
l'urgence nous calmera rien je pense
qu'au contraire c'est remettre une pièce
dans le jokebox et ça va encore plus
amener de violence donc
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas de garantie mais
je crois qu'il faut vraiment apaiser
apaiser plus vite et j'espère que ça va
s'apaiser et que si on n'y arrive pas
peut-être que il y aura peut-être une
nécessité de mettre les deux dans une
semaine ou deux semaines mais il faut
donner la chance ou avoir l'espoir de
réussir à apaiser quand même est-ce que
quand le président de la République em
Macron parle à propos du policier d'un
geste inexcusable je vais pas vous
mettre en défaut mais est-ce qu'il parle
pas un peu vite au fond il y a une
enquête on va voir peut-être que des
excuses j'en sais rien mais est-ce que
c'est des éléments que nous n'avons pas
je pense pas est-ce que c'est pas
peut-être pas parler un peu vite est-ce
que ça peut pas provoquer encore plus la
colère
je pense que le terme qu'il a utilisé
était aussi destiné à la famille parce
qu'effectivement quand il y a la mort
d'un enfant c'est voilà on peut pas
simplement présenter des excuses et
c'est effectivement un acte inexcusable
je crois que la première ministre s'est
exprimée différemment elle a dit que
visiblement là la procédure n'avait pas
été la procédure officielle les les
gestes n'étaient pas se recommander donc
on voit bien qu'il y a quand même une
différence entre les pratiques normales
de la police et ce qui s'est passé là
donc après l'enquête détaillera
exactement ce qui s'est passé et on peut
faire une différence puisque on parlera
de 2005 tout à l'heure là il se trouve
le policier est mis en examen et même et
même a été
une réponse judiciaire souvent on dit
voilà la justice ne répond pas assez
vite là elle répond pour le coup oui par
rapport à ce que dit elle irait
finalement ce phénomène dans les
Nouradine l'a dit c'est pas nouveau il y
a toujours eu des difficultés entre les
jeunes des quartiers et les policiers
quand il dit il indique aussi que il
manque de moyens au niveau de la police
nationale peut-être municipal aussi que
finalement les violences policières on
les a jamais vraiment peut-être prises
en compte et que tout ça ça fait un
cocktail explosif comment vous réagissez
quelle réponse on peut apporter
justement à ce cocktail explosif et puis
résoudre
majorité à tout fait pour remettre du
bleu sur le terrain et remettre des
zones sur le terrain donc il y a eu 10
000 hommes sur le premier mandat donc
qui ont été rajoutés sur le terrain et
le département des Yvelines a été
pas envie comme tous les autres
départements mais au même relativement
largement donc j'ai plus le chiffre en
tête exactement des policiers mais je
suis sûre convaincue qu'il y a eu des
policiers qui ont été rajoutés à
plusieurs étapes à plusieurs périodes
aussi bon c'est pas mon territoire mais
je sais par exemple qu'un plaisir il y
avait eu que 4 en 2020 je crois il y en
a eu 5 je crois cette année il y en a eu
aussi sur le nord du département à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye il y en a eu sur
Versailles il y en a eu c'est sûr aussi
à Élancourt donc on a rajouté des hommes
sur le terrain parce que depuis de
nombreuses années on diminué le nombre
de fonctionnaires en diminuant le nombre
de policiers donc là aujourd'hui on fait
des mais il faut aussi le temps de
formation de ces jeunes il faut voilà
prise en compte des violences policières
ce qu'il faut aller plus loin dans la
sanction dans la manière de de traiter
ce genre d'affaires
je crois que les médias insistent
beaucoup et parlent beaucoup de toutes
ces nouvelles
difficultés qu'il quand on regarde les
chiffres
il baisse enfin de compte donc on a
parlé là de ce tir quand on regarde le
nombre d'usages des armes à feu dans la
police notamment sur sur les citoyens
qui n'obtèrent pas les chiffres baissent
d’années après année
en Allemagne
mais il y a aussi une autre chose mais
il faut qu'on aille un peu vite
peut-être
les mères parfois demandent aussi
d'avoir plus de responsabilités dans la
sécurité ce qui serait pas mieux à
mettre de répondre à ce genre de
situation d'urgence je pense que tous
les maires ont leur police municipale ou
en moins les villes d'une certaine
taille municipale suffit ils ont
aujourd'hui une latitude il y a des
poésies municipales qui sont armés qui
sont formés
et je crois que partout aujourd'hui les
polices municipales travaillent main
dans la main avec la police nationale et
au moins sur mon territoire j'ai pas
j'ai pas d'informations comme quoi il y
aurait un conflit entre les polices
municipales et police nationale mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a un certain nombre
de maire dont votre collègue Caroline
quand il était qui demandait au fond que
les la sécurité soit dans la compétence
des maires plutôt que de l'État avec
l'argent
globale attribuée aux villes depuis
un transfert de de budget forcément
justement puisqu'on parle de la de la
baisse des effectifs des policiers je
propose de de rien d'interview de
Guillaume doré qui secrétaire régional
du syndicat à Lyon police nationale 78
malheureusement dans les Yvelines on a
on a beaucoup de problèmes d'effectifs
on a ça fait des années qu'on a très peu
de sorties d'école maintenant pour
remplacer les départs et effectivement
hier c'était un peu compliqué
pour pour gérer la situation crise ce
sera ça le sera maintenant moins
puisqu'il va y avoir des renforts encore
plus qui vont arriver mais effectivement
oui on ressent quand même que qu'on a
besoin de plus de monde
voilà problème des effectifs mais qui
d'un problème récurrents
est-ce qu'on va mettre un policier
derrière chaque
réponse pour essayer de répondre à ces
questions
qui sont beaucoup plus profondes qu'une
simple enfin une simple entre guillemets
parce que le problème est très important
la relation jeune des quartiers et
police effectivement est une des
composantes majeures de ce problème
mais il y a des problèmes beaucoup plus
importants structurant est-ce que ces
jeunes ont une chance de s'en sortir
est-ce que l'école est au niveau dans
ces quartiers
l'emploi deux fois plus de chômage au
niveau des jeunes dans ces quartiers que
dans la moyenne nationale ça on peut
mettre 150
000 policiers à Trappes si ces jeunes
n'ont pas de de solutions n'ont pas de
capital culturels comme les autres n'ont
pas les mêmes chances à l'école n'ont
pas voilà l'occasion d'aller au théâtre
de de faire comme tout le monde alors on
peut mettre les policiers ce sera super
ça rassurera peut-être
quelques habitants mais bon ça ne va pas
faire changer la situation mais c'est
pour ça que quand on parle de ces
violons c'est de cette cocotte-minute
qui explose on voit bien que les les
problèmes qui sont en deçà sont énormes
je voudrais qu'on revienne avec vous
Nicolas puisqu'on en a parlé et
rapidement pardon sur ce qui s'est passé
en 2005 puisque on compare beaucoup la
situation d'aujourd'hui avec celle de
2005 après la mort de
boudins alors c'était le 27 octobre 2005
les émeutes débutent à Clichy-sous-Bois
et elles ont duré trois semaines en
Île-de-France et dans toute la France et
alors à 50 ans en Yvelines c'était ça a
commencé par cet épisode une vingtaine
de bus incendiés au dépôt de 50 ans en
Yvelines du skibus le réseau de
transport urbain de l'agglomération
c'était le 4 novembre 2005 au matin à
Trappes après une nuit d'émeutes c'est
le premier événement marquant de cette
crise sociale et on écoute à ce propos
le responsable de l'exploitation de bus
de l'époque je pense qu'on est sur un un
réseau le réseau de 50 ans en Yvelines
où il y a très peu d'aide et que nous
avions jamais été confrontés à ce genre
de préoccupation notre priorité pour une
entreprise de transport et de mettre à
disposition donc les autobus et de
rétablir de tout urgence l'offre pour
nos clients voyageurs alors au moment de
du bilan à la fin novembre 2005 le
préfet des Yvelines de l'époque Bernard
[__] a fait le bilan 65 communes
touchées 150 véhicules incendiés 20
bâtiment public pris pour cible sur
l'ensemble de la période 120 personnes
interpellées 81 ont été présentées
devant la justice en comparation
immédiate et parmi elles 41 ont été
emprisonnés les Yvelines avaient été le
département le plus touché à l'époque et
face à la situation nationale le Premier
ministre de l'époque Dominique de
Villepin avait déclenché l'état
d'urgence le 8 novembre le préfet des
Yvelines pouvait activer un couvre-feu
dans le département il ne l'a pas fait
on l'écoute la situation
qui montre même si je dis ça avec
beaucoup de réserves et beaucoup de
prudence qui montrent une évidence
amélioration
ne justifie pas en l'état que je prenne
puisque c'est une décision du préfet que
je prenne un arrêté par exemple de
couvre-feu
cela étant
si les circonstances exigaient si la
situation de se dégradait je suis en
mesure à tout instant et à toute heure
de prendre les décisions dans ce domaine
qui s'imposent
alors néanmoins dans les Yvelines le mer
UMP d'Élancourt Jean-Michel fourgousse a
pris un arrêté municipal pour un
couvre-feu entre 22h et 5 heures du
matin alors au-delà de cette décision
politique locale les élus incontinois
avaient réagi à l'époque par rapport à
ses émeutes il y a un travail important
qui est fait sur le terrain travail fait
par la police municipale travail réalisé
aussi par les équipes d'éducateurs de la
dire qui sont très présents sur le
terrain qui vont au contact des jeunes
qui sont là le soir sont d'ailleurs
pourquoi il y a des jeunes et mineurs
qui sont dehors jusqu'à des heures très
très avancées on a fait aussi un travail
avec certaines associations culturelles
notamment en situation arrêt que
l'association des ressortissants
africains des Yvelines qui aussi nous a
permis d'avoir un dialogue avec
certaines communautés il faut cesser
cette violence et pour cesser cette
violence il faut aussi que ceux qui
prononcent des des propos provocateurs
inadmissible à la limite on ne nettoie
pas nos quartiers au karcher nous
nous travaillons avec les gens en
appliquant rigoureusement la loi et
c'est un autre propos et donc il faut
aussi que que ce personnage et ce qu'il
l'entourent cesse d'avoir cette attitude
à augmenter et inacceptable parce que il
s'asserre de prétexte
alors dans cet extrait on le voit bien
un guimalandin fait référence en fait il
répondait à Nicolas Sarkozy à leur
ministre de l'Intérieur qui avait parlé
du jeu site de nettoyer aucun cher les
quartiers alors effectivement Patrice on
voit qui a eu des événements et alors il
y a eu un événement assez important et
assez conséquent la mort d'une personne
le 21 novembre 2005 des voitures
stationnées dans la cour du lycée de la
plaine de Neauphle sont ainsi endié et
le gardien de l'établissement Alain
Lambert 52 ans tente d'éteindre le feu
victime d'un arrêt cardiaque il décède
dans la foulée l'autopsie révélera que
les fumées de l'incendie l'ont
empoisonné le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Gilles de Robien avait fait le
déplacement
pour faire cela jeune ou moins jeune il
faut être irresponsable il faut vraiment
avoir le désir de nuire et ce type
d'acte doit être évidemment condamné
avec beaucoup de fermeté j'espère qu'on
va trouver les auteurs et j'espère
qu'ils seront punis à la hauteur de
leurs actes alors dans la lune pardon
dans le lycée c'est la stupeur et les
élèves s'organisent pour rendre hommage
à Alain Lambert
on ressent à la famille et une lettre
ouverte aussi on va essayer de faire
intervenir le maire pour lui dire s'il
pourrait pas écrire une lettre pour les
habitants de trap en fait pour dire ce
qui s'est passé voilà maintenant faut
qu'il sache maintenant maintenant faut
qu'il sache que ce qu'ils ont tué un
homme
alors si on peut faire une comparaison
c'est qu'il y a eu un élément
déclencheur toujours un problème entre
les jeunes et la police qui a conduit au
DC de ces jeunes et puis après s'ensuit
des violences alors peut-être à un
niveau un peu plus fort
par rapport à ce que nous on peut nous
dire les forces de l'ordre dans nos
échanges dans la journée et aujourd'hui
un peu plus aujourd'hui un peu plus
forte aujourd'hui et alors voilà juste
mettre en garde ce qui peut se passer on
peut arriver à un drame comme on l'a eu
en 2005 avec la disparition d'Alain
Lambert le gardien du lycée de la plaine
de nos flattrappe alors un mot sur le je
crois qu'il y a 45 interpellations après
les les événements de séduit et puis il
y a pas d'état d'urgence mais les
transports s'arrêtent à 21h
à rencontrer a pris la décision avec la
préfecture de police de Paris de
suspendre le service des transports à
partir de 21h ce soir donc attention il
faut prendre ses précautions à 20h plus
ces tramways de toute la région
Île-de-France
voilà voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire
aujourd'hui après ces deux nuits
d'émeutes peut-être qu'on sera
malheureusement obligé de revenir sur ce
sujet merci beaucoup Béatrice Piron
merci beaucoup Noéline Agne et merci
beaucoup Nicolas dandry et je vous
laisse dans quelques instants avec
Mathilde de Franco pour faire le point
sur
l'autre va sur l'autre actualité
[Musique]